this of course in your hand becomes
super bar that's not in fact you have
been talking about the last ten years it
gives in the rapid progress as when the
last one year has been a blip mark
because of India but because of the
world economy and what we do not really
having place j2me and goonrock towards
is the surety political will to make it
happen having the very government in the
second session and it's a much better
work position we definitely help but at
the same time the willingness of the
it's beautiful people with the private
sector as there is the social sector to
make the problems happen is extremely
important in the private sector director
to premier 11 days the new enterprise of
the still businesses the people have
just ready to go and move on to hear
that is also reflected me versus
initiatives and our interests have taken
we want to also play in a way that our
total population and our huge is a
totally motivated and brought together
to play a role in this progress it may
be a five-year plan or a 20-year plan
and depending on how then we manage the
process at the minimum the twentieth
plan before if we have a problem is
going to change the education say this
is the most important reform that we
need to put in place and in the pantheon
of 20 to 30 blurs it is so possible
submersible that I'll be surprised if
you don't enjoy
you